we survived the blizzard coffee on a
Tuesday and vlog 49 life often perfectly
manageable is sometimes subject to
intense and revealing human moments
moments when the inscrutable veil that
is the exterior of ourselves suddenly
becomes transparent so that anyone in
the vicinity who can see us can also see
through us you know what I mean if
you've ever been embarrassed or seen
someone embarrassed you know what I mean
the machinations behind the eyes
normally so Swift and indecipherable
fall away and you are left with a person
so utterly and pathetically readable we
try our best to avoid moments like this
it's in our interest to be a mystery
most of the time in social relationships
people value unpredictability so we're
unpredictable and there is no nakedness
more naked than the experience of being
figured out but here at nerdwriter
industries we love this kind of moment
because it tells us something about
people about naked people and we love
people at their most naked no wait that
came out wrong
or did it I live in New York City and I
ride the subway every day the subway
like a cafe is a place where people are
alone together most people read books or
listen to music or just stare off into
the middle distance the subway is not a
destination it's a place between
destinations and we have no intention of
making it a destination so we all agree
not to speak to one another now one
thing about the New York subway is that
it does have panhandlers homeless people
people down on their luck asking for
money and it's a pretty frequent
occurrence exacerbated I'd imagine by
the state of the economy these people
despite their misfortunes wield and
incredible power when they come onto the
train and give their speech always
practiced always forceful they create
one of these intense and revealing human
moments and a subway car of fifty opaque
Souls becomes as transparent as clean
water as the downtrodden person either
with musical instruments a sad face
child or an emaciated dog comes down the
subway car hat in hand they force each
and every rider to confront their
desperation a couple give a few coins or
a dollar some look up and shake their
heads
most people just stare aggressively into
their books or at their feet ignoring
and refusing the shameless person's
existence people on the subway don't
want this
that's obvious a beggar violates the
agreed rules of the situation not to
interact the fact is that this person
who may need food or money to house
their children or money to pay for power
has presented the train car with an
explicit moral problem should you give
them money or not try as we might there
is no way once posed not to answer this
question I guess that the riders
intuitive dislike of being forced to do
something in a place where they expect
to do nothing is what influences most of
them not to give and make no mistake
most people don't this echoes the theme
of my last vlog we use our reason to
justify our feelings if you're offended
by this person to start then here are
some reasons not to get maybe they won't
use the money for food but instead for
drugs maybe maybe I'm making the problem
worse this is my money I earned it I
worked hard for it they have no right to
that I don't have enough money myself to
be giving it away to others well you
know I only have a 5 dollar bill in my
wallet if I had a dollar bill or some
coins you know I'd do it but you know
fives too much you know what this will
only perpetuate their homelessness I
know about these things
they need to get a job I can't give
every day how much how much they want
for me I'm not gonna solve their
problems it's useless to give it all if
your inclination on the other hand is to
give then you have to ask should you
give everytime and how much and to whom
and knowing that beggars are gonna be on
the subway should you be sure to have
money with you always when you leave the
house should you beat yourself up when
you forget is it enough to deal with
poverty only when it crosses your path
should you be allowed to feel good about
yourself if you give only once and it's
only a die there are no easy answers to
these questions nor is there an easy
answer to the first question the one in
the moment when they hold out their hand
all I can say is try not to make the
perfect the enemy of the good what I do
know is that the no stops this line of
questioning in its tracks while the yes
opens up that vast moral web in which we
are forced to consider the needs and
desires of others forced to confront and
work out our messy responsibilities in
relation to everyone else still the fact
is given the truth that almost everyone
doesn't give that there are a good
number
people like me that decide that they
should but don't
I think this tension incites a valuable
pain in our hearts but I have to wonder
is it valuable enough
[Music]
I see great